mine's i like your pet i like your
patrick my home song better i do too i
mean what's special when you have a
special voice like me and my homie my
homie my homie whenever he's on i watch
my homie my homie my homie damn i'm good
whew greatest hits album right there
the other song you heard was patrick
holmes uh curiously enough titled by
slick with two caves never heard of
slick but i've heard of patrick mahomes
and you're going to be hearing a lot
about patrick holmes the chiefs and the
49ers the
chiefs
initially and the 49ers it was a pickum
line it moved to minus one for the
chiefs last night then it was one and a
half the last time i checked wow the
early betting coming in on the chiefs
did they not watch the 49ers yesterday
chris as i was watching the 49ers the
49ers dismantle the packers my thought
was i don't know how the chiefs can keep
up with this team because here's the
thing down 24 nothing to the texans they
came back and won down 17-7 to the
titans they came back and won i almost
feel like if you go down seven nothing
to the 49ers you're gonna have a hard
time coming back well i mean yes but i i
would never say that with mahomes and i
think like listen i'm with you
i think if if i was setting the line i
probably would have favored san
francisco by one one and a half maybe
two points yeah i do think they're the
better team but the best player on the
field is wearing red and he's number 15
and that does equal a lot of things out
and he equals out a lot of the strengths
or things that the 49ers overwhelm you
with
mahomes they have the pass protection he
has the ability to
you know buy time there avoid those pass
rushers make plays down the field too so
that's going to be interesting but uh i
i you know i think yesterday's got to
give you confidence a little bit with
how they played derek henry that they
can at least slow down the 49ers that
there's that possibility in the run game
and then i don't know mike i mean what's
your what's your first look and when you
think of the 49ers defense versus
mahomes in that offense where do you
think that goes because you know that's
arguably the best offense and best
defense in football facing off on each
other right now and i know that the
49ers were two and the chiefs are like
six but you know they missed some weeks
without and uh patrick mahomes that
they're one of the best offenses in the
game
i think the closest the 49ers have seen
to an offense like the chiefs is what
they saw when they played the rams twice
and they manhandled the rams the first
time around and the rams aren't in the
chief's class issue but from the
standpoint of weapons you can flood
the secondary with travis kelsey sammy
watkins tyree kill we talked earlier
about that when you have all three guys
it's like the pressure the texans put on
the defense i just don't know that that
san francisco secondary can hold up if
patrick mahomes constantly moving right
you can't get a radar lock on him if
you're joey bosa and company can mahomes
buy enough time by constantly moving
constantly shifting constantly running
to find guys open deliver the football
and can they avoid falling behind early
10-00 17-0 20-nothing they can't do that
no they can't got to come out of the
gates hot andy reed needs to spend the
next two weeks coming up with a scheme
that is aimed at allowing the chiefs to
score
quickly and i think both teams are going
to try to deliver the knockout punch
early and you know what happens when
you're trying to deliver knockout punch
you're exposed to a knockout punch
that's why this thing could be very
interesting right out of the gates and
who knows maybe by halftime it'll it'll
be one of those games where we're like
oh boy it's like it was in the 70s or
the 80s why are we watching because it's
on tv and uh you know it's still the
super bowl even if it's a blowout yeah i
would be shocked though if we saw a
blowout i really would i just think uh
you know there's a lot of things here
there's too much talent on both sides of
the football i don't think we're gonna
see that type of game you know i think
mahomes the offense they're special they
have such belief they're flying high
right now their defense has got to feel
good about where they are as well i mean
they've played as good of defense as
we've seen and you know again you know
i'm with you i think the 49ers are the
better more complete football team but
not by a wide margin and mahomes closes
that margin and the other thing i'll say
is you know you think about the 49ers
losses this year lamar jackson russell
wilson guys that could create and go
above and beyond the scheme well and we
know this guy can do that too so that's
that's something to watch out for
and watch the weather forecast because
it can rain in miami and who has played
in a couple of rhett and wayne rhett and
wayne again and wet and rainy games
see you tuesday everybody have a good
day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports